thrilled to have here in person one of
our favorite actors
from usa networks the center currently
in season four wednesdays at 10 eastern
time on usa network bill pullman how are
you sir good to see you good to see you
rich good to be here you got it we are
all of us we just i don't know if you
heard it back in the green room we named
like about half of uh our favorite film
list and you're in all of them oh pretty
much good pretty much
good which one do you get whenever
you're around people walk up to you and
give you what which film you know i i
i it's a it's i can
i sometimes try to guess because you see
a look in their eye that they're coming
towards you
you know is this a casper person or is
this a
independence day person or is it a wire
sleeping person or is it a center now
it's like sinner you know because it's
great fortunately the
thing had has had a life you know but uh
and i'm always wrong
i'm always wrong okay yeah i i
lately i'm surprised of how many
international people like in new york
city when i'm walking around people from
all around the world happen to be
able to get into the center okay so uh
you know and they don't even remember or
know that i'm in other things
yeah come on it's life rich that's crazy
that's great though that you got so so
what do you think has been so um you
know connective to your fans about the
center like what do you think has worked
yeah i i always was uh i have
not only a kind of illiterate about
sports as i've told you just before we
started i i have my own way into sports
i should say because i enjoy it but i
don't follow the statistics and that
this the same is true television i not
the best viewer of
all my
compadres who are out there working in
television sure but i i just seem to
have other things that i can't
leave
and so but i i do think that uh the idea
of addicting television you know people
say i like that show i'm addicted to it
you know it says something about the
power of uh
a season
and then another season and another
season and i realized that uh i finally
understand that you know and i and i'm
okay with it sure okay bill pullman here
on the rich eisen show so you're from
western new york right yes i learned a
long time ago uh in my capacity of the
host of nfl network to not call
buffalo
upstate new york
because i'm from staten island new york
yeah to call buffalo upstate new york i
was told by many bills fans that work
around nfl network that that's a slight
and i apologize because they like
western europe that's what you're
western you're not upstate you're
western new york so did you grow up
around the bills like was that uh a team
that was like forefront of yeah your
life yeah but
the you know and that's why it's not
called antelope the city is called
buffalo it is western
in its own way you know
but i and i know what you mean about the
the
the nature of the bills and their
connection to all of that area of new
york state is so important i think
because
uh
they have an identity complex you know
we get forgotten out there by the albany
that's really
east and
hudson valley all that stuff yeah yeah
and a lot of people if you say you're
from new york they'll immediately say
well i don't hear your accent
and
i you know in western new york state
it's practically ohio right that people
sound like ohio right they have country
accents and things like that so the
bills you know uh bring you together the
you know wings barbecue wings sure uh
and watching the bills is a cultural
thing you never tailgated you ever
jumped off an rv into a flaming table
like the rest of the bill's fans bill
palmand you've never you've never done
that how serious they are you know they
yeah they got it uh but yeah i i did uh
you know i i just i like the apparel
yeah you know i think the buffalo
signature it is pretty cool no i i i
know and it had a dark you know i like
the underdog thing i mean they that was
such a long stretch where they didn't
win that's exactly right i know record
breaking right how many do you know
offhand it was 25 years until last year
bill pullman that the buffalo bills had
not made the playoffs after that string
of going to the super bowl four straight
years and not winning and what have you
and i just loved when they bills got off
the plane to you know make the afc
championship game and then lose it and
then the fans all showed up at the
airport and went totally crazy yeah they
are really passionate i remember going
into my first tailgate at um at a
buffalo bills game um covering it for
nfl network and i'm like oh god there's
about three bonfires here i'm like oh
god you're like this is this
this is lit literally and figuratively
yes everything
it's so cool i love it bill coleman here
on the rich eisen show okay bill we have
some first things first you said that
you could tell
which person which fan approaches you
what their
favorite part of your filmography is can
you you want to try that with me
because i know i mentioned a couple
films already but you want to give it a
whirl just look at me and see what i i
what i am i i liked well i did over here
the last seduction is you gave it a
thumbs up and i thought
that's always good when when someone
goes for the noir and you know i went i
went the other direction not your big
pop tentpole films correct yes but um
that is not the one the one for me is
spaceballs oh
for real because i am a mel brooks
junkie
when it comes down to it high anxiety
young frankenstein
obviously the producers blazing saddles
mel brooks is one of my favorites of all
time what was that like working with him
wow you know did you see it first on
screen or on my channel i saw it on the
screen on screen i did i went to the
moment it was 85 and you would have been
like 15 or 14. no i i was bless you for
that actually no i was just about to go
to college i was 18 i was about 17 years
old that's like straight heroin no
yes for a mel brooks you know jewish kid
from new york who grew up loving mel
brooks man it was just like okay mel
brooks meets star wars i am all the way
i am well you know
my uh i i always loved and i do love
that jewish side of him because it's old
you know it's old vaudeville it's old
yeah
yeah yeah
caesar i mean you got to be way back in
the day man just yeah genetically it's
in it's in them all the way and you know
my wife is jewish and my my
father-in-law al
herwitz you know which always uh has a
certain sense of humor but mel used to
come up to me and goes
pullman
you guys
if such good hair
i mean i got hair it's like it's like
brillo and you've got such good hair you
know he touched me you know it's
affection in a weird wild way
it's good to be the king yeah kind of
like that
what a genius i mean this and i always
think about him with baseballs in terms
of the the power nap
because he would be you know he just
said say i i'm just going to go down for
about five minutes and he'd come up and
a thousand things had occurred to him
are you serious yeah like he would just
tap out and say i needed just a power
nap and then he would come back and then
yeah he said we need to change that line
it needs to be not orange but purple
purple's funnier you know
stuff like that which sounded like
wisdom to me
sounds like well i mean you would know
which color is funnier well we we have a
bunch of questions from your career here
um in celebrity true or false where
these are from articles that have been
written about you or from bios that have
been placed online about you and we need
to know what's true and what's false
okay we have production value on top of
it bill pullman live here in the rich
eyes and show studio roll it please roll
it
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
all right it's that simple it's that's
the setup that's the setup
that's all we got we have no fireworks
did he say you can't handle the truth
that's it right there i believe in that
okay here we go so um
true or false bill pullman uh when
promoting independence day in south
america some people actually thought you
were the real president of the united
states is that true or false
well i i yeah i think that they hadn't
seen the movie yet
and they told they were told that i was
pres at the president of the united
states you know
if you lose the word
in the movie you know are those words it
just becomes you're the president of the
united states and uh
it kicked in some really interesting
things and probably the most bizarre was
they had kind of cigarette girls
that were with little pillbox hats and
uh and short skirts and everything and
they uh
they walked down the red carpet with me
and i think i got that
because i didn't know the presidents get
that
i thought that's a good deal
and i i think it was because they
thought i was the president i don't know
maybe but uh yeah there was that a
feeling it was a good period and then
after people saw the movie they realized
you're not the real president
is it true that that scene with you with
the bullhorn and rallying the troops to
fight the aliens that was one take one
and done no that's not true that's not
true not true yeah i never heard that
that's a true thing that's out there is
that exactly what we were talking about
yeah yeah bill we've heard that uh you
were just so into it and everyone was
just so caught up in the moment of the
speech there was one take and they just
had to reshoot kind of people's
reactions oh man well we did have to go
fast
and it was late in the it was early
morning when we did it you know it was
like three or four in the morning or
something yeah but um you know with when
you're dealing with a director like
roland emerick you got masters you got
you know all that i think what was
was really improvisational about it was
uh
kept you know and i realized that they
probably used those early takes because
like when the microphone didn't work and
i had to kind of tap it and everything
that was kind of real okay yeah so that
was all you know happening but um
i think i i think i had a few whacks at
it you know you have to be ready to
sustain i love the mythology i did it in
one take yes
i take richie that's the way i refer to
myself sometimes on this uh show
that that is the mythology of it i guess
and and so um
for is it also true that you're asked as
bill pullman to be the president of the
united states again and that voice and
just do all sorts of crazy stuff is that
true yeah all the time it's uh
there's
just uh it's somehow
buried in people but then you realize
maybe they want me to go i don't need to
do that but do you know the speech and
then they'll perform the whole speech
for you is that right yeah i've had that
probably 10 times you know where i've
actually said do you know i had some
inkling you know and yeah i had to do it
from in they want they were hoping that
i would get to see him do it you know
which is i'd like that better than me
having to
you want me to do this yes
am i a dog with a bone
it's that good yeah
yeah
it was you rallied the truth
against the aliens you saved the planet
that's right that's right i mean do you
want me to do it right now i mean okay
and i can do it right now can you really
do it right now i have the text okay no
no no that's not the same that's not the
same
you can't google it with bill pullman
sitting here late all right uh here's
the next one true or false bill pullman
you still have the jacket you wore and
while you were sleeping is that true or
false that is true where is that where's
the jacket i you know
it would imply it's not that is it that
jacket that's no it's um it's a dude
it's a reversible jacket and it has
denim on one side and a kind of a tan on
the other
so i i don't want you to get the feeling
rich that i have a lot of stuff from my
movies in my house you know that would
be a little weird and but
i do have probably more than a normal
person does but i i do uh for some
reason i was always digging the
reversible idea
you know uh of jackets and clothes and
stuff that that's right gone out of
fashion i think so you kept it not for
some sort of uh i guess memento keepsake
but you kind of like that it's in the
closet it becomes no nobody sees me
wearing it goes is that from
what
what
so you still catch on you stole it while
wardrobe was sleeping or they knew that
you took it that's right
what was it disney was a little more
free with them with their goods in those
days you know it was bona vista which
owned by this dave i guess but it was
right yeah i made off with it which was
really good i i did you know turtletop
is a and i love that you are friends
with him yes he's one of the great uh
per people and directors i agree i agree
and just my wife when i told her you
were going to be on this show that's the
first movie that blurted out of her
mouth she will watch that's a
re-watchable for her yeah all the time i
did i've seen that movie a lot on the
team i'm like again you know like that's
that's yeah that's what happens in my
house a lot i i wonder if john watches
it again i think if john's wondering
anything he's where the hell did that
reversible jacket go
i wanted it for you know i want i wanted
it for you know national treasure and we
couldn't use it because um you know it's
pretty cool man that so
are you surprised about the staying
power of that film for you
yeah yeah that was really not uh
you know i think even john said it on
the last day of the shoot you know he
said i don't know
whether anybody's ever going to see it's
if this is not might not this movie goes
away you know
and uh but i want to
say that it's been really significant
for me and this experience has been
significant for me and i appreciate what
good we had this time together and so
you know he
i think that was uh because it and it i
think it was largely his contribution
because it i remember a few people out
of sight of their mouth said this is a
tv script
you know that it was somehow too
pleasant
you know too friendly in some way
but i don't think they realize there's
something in the dna of it that is
classic you know and definitely sandy is
so fantastic and i'm so lucky to get
paired with jack warden and you know oh
sure peter boyle peter boyle i mean
speaking of young frankenstein i mean
that's
young frankenstein that's peter boyle
yeah
sure i went on to do a couple movies
with him yeah just so great and i such
so graceful and all those guys were and
so i i've always think of them as my
ancestors in a way pretty cool man a
couple of uh spaceballs questions uh
true or false it was rumored that mel
brooks wanted you and daphne zaniga to
get back together and do a sequel is
that true well you know he put it in the
movie you know this is for space balls
too the search for more money
i forgot about that so
you know that's deep philosophy you know
let's name it we need more money but uh
i think uh yeah i
uh would certainly be great but uh
i i think it you know it's hard without
candy and you know of course and that
was the other question is it true that
he that he um ad-libbed his famous line
of that's going to leave a mark is that
true uh
that's going to leave a mark yeah yeah
is that did he ad-lib that or was it
script yeah i mean come on yeah
i i use that still today
my friends and i still use that but it's
it's a quintessential john candy it's so
off the cuff
it's so gentle humor you know it's not
banging over your head it's just like
and he he was a special
you know he danced with comedy as just
the slightest graceful thing the
sweetheart right i never obviously was
ever around him what was that like to be
around him yeah it was just my you know
it was my second movie and i was he saw
me as a guy in need and he took me under
his wing what do you mean well you know
it was
yeah on the ladder the mgm lot one of
the last movies that was made on that
lot as when it was still mgm and you
know busy and i
was off the farm practically to in his
eyes you know he saw that and
uh but he would uh
go he'd say come on you want to go you
want to have lunch in the trailer you
know and things like that and what how
are you are you happy you know what's
going on you know so he he looked out
for me that's so cool and you got that
gig out of ruthless people right is that
how it worked you were ruthless people
and then to well the mouse said he tried
to get a tom tom hanks tom cruise and he
couldn't get a tom so he got a bill
which i think always amused him yeah
in other words you're from nowhere man
and i was really from nowhere and he and
anne bancroft came down to see me in a
play you know they saw me in this weird
abstract uh barabbas this uh medieval
passion play kind of thing
he had a lot to say about it you know
and yeah it was it was really uh a
special thing that he uh
yanked me out of the
farm league no kidding see i know a
little about let's see come on bill come
on you know you you know what you know
man and again we know you're in uh the
center tonight 10 eastern time on usa
network currently in season four
um and um like i said we're huge fans of
yours man ah and thanks for thanks for
coming in here great i appreciate that
really great to be on your show thank
you so much for saying that i know chris
you're you're do you want to do one line
i know you do like you're desperate to
do one line
then now i switched over and i started
doing spaceball lines in my head because
i could go with that movie beginning to
end like on this ship you'll refer me as
hey idiot not your captain okay you got
the lines backwards just like
do you get that a lot or that's a first
for you right there give me no give me
pause i still remember you know
that was also you know because that was
early for uh uh green screen and we were
doing in the winnebago and there's green
screen they were that we had to wear uh
sunglasses in between the takes and he
improvised that when we were in between
a take so he was not only saying give me
paul but he he had sunglasses on when he
did it and i thought that was cool can
we keep the sunglasses but no we
oh my god pizza the hut and like well
darth hellman
[Laughter]
we're not just saying it thanks again
for coming here matt this has been great
bill pullman everybody right here on the
rich eyes and show everyone check out
the center again tonight and every
wednesday 10 eastern time on usa network
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here